all right boom boom boom it was
basic basically used as a way to
maintain Mobility flexibility just think
it was a very fancy number
told you I've been practicing I know I'm
very impressed hey friends we are back
learning some traditional Maori short
POI and today Tash is going to be
showing me some fun bounces that happen
around with just one hand
that sounds a fun one drexier from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of boy spinning and flowers to benefit
your body and brain and today I am
learning some more awesome short boy
style before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Becca beckonen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission hey so we're back
with my friend Tash who is the friendly
Maori bartender from up the street who
uh by sheer random habits dance it turns
out he grew up around POI and is now
teaching me some fun koi stuff so um fun
fact the stuff we're doing in this video
is stuff that Tosh actually showed me a
few weeks ago and was the whole reason I
wanted to do this video series
um I had gotten a set of these uh POI
from potiki POI and I brought them into
show Tosh and she pulled something right
out that absolutely blew my mind so now
we're going to show all of you which she
showed me that night to me up around it
this was just a normal
thing that you would do to basically
stim I guess and it is this
all right so the anatomy what's going on
here basically so we start off with the
POI hitting like the wrist underneath as
we're pointing our uh our Palm up
towards the sky we're kind of pulling it
around into a buzz sock plane the POI
spinning reverse and then you're kind of
flicking your hand up and letting the
POI hit the back of your wrist and then
reversing the direction of it so it
comes around forwards and Buzz saw you
kind of open up your palm towards the
sky and let it hit the bottom of your
wrist to start over again right yes cool
and you it all becomes one motion like
you're you're your wrist is
basically move it while your hand and
your wrist are moving in Unison with the
ball so let me show you what this looks
like in slow-mo right quick because
it'll help break it down
told you I've been practicing I know I'm
very impressed so the night Tash showed
this to me I had a really tough time
figuring out what was going on and part
of the reason is that it requires a
whole lot of wrist movement and that is
something that we contemporary POI
Spinners don't really do a lot of touch
do you want to show what that wrist
movement looks like right quick so
specifically you are just
rotating your wrist like this
so we're going from like a palm up kind
of place and rolling it around to a palm
down kind of place yes
so we're done
so like if you follow where my index
finger is going here I'm going from like
pointing up pointing away down around
and then back down with my palm up
just think it was a very fancy now
so one thing I do want to talk about
right click here also is length as we're
doing this like where where exactly do
you want to have uh the POI length in
order to make this work almost
for me my spacing would probably be like
a fist width
I find that it contacts the back of my
hand and wrist in an area that I feel
more control like I can control it a
little bit better the direction it's
gonna hit you can do it a little bit
longer yeah but for me it'll hit a
little too far down on here
while I can still do it it's not
the best yeah
so one thing that I got wrong as I was
watching this the first time and Tosh
needed to uh to to kind of correct me on
is that you're basically aiming for the
same spot in your wrist no matter what
whether you're like doing the uh doing
the Bounce from under your wrist or from
over your wrist you're still aiming for
this spot uh just past where uh the top
of your wrist is all your major movement
for this is coming from the elbow down
and then not even
that much movement here other than
turning the back backwards and forwards
so you're you're basically just moving
to meet the ball where it would be when
it completes one rotation
um another thing I'm thinking about
right here though I don't think was
really obvious to me the first night we
were playing around with this is just
that again it kind of uh it's less a up
down motion with your with your forearm
you're just kind of like letting it hang
out there in space this is just
completely down to the movement of the
wrist yes it's you we're just trying to
keep these limber yes basically and you
were telling me at one point too that
like part of the reason that like these
exercises were developed was to develop
wrist flexibility right yes to help with
fighting okay oh dear
no so uh asmori we did this back in the
day it was men and woman it was
basic basically used as a way to
maintain Mobility flexibility
dexterity and hand-eye coordination
for fighting but it was it was too like
it was a peaceful way to maintain it
interesting so doing this works your
wrist muscles it's your hand-eye
coordination it's keeping all of these
limber and then literally if you've
never done this type of movement before
in two minutes it's making your arm
cramp up and be like I didn't know I had
muscles there totally yes and then if
you want to get fancy
I do you know I do this is a case where
you are heading it on to opposite
wow okay okay so I'm taking it off the
top hit and uh your your wrist becomes
the other Palm if you were doing
this you're you're interesting
all right boom boom boom I still have
not quite mastered that direction
I guess I didn't tell people to come
here very often oh so that's interesting
like you know we were talking in the
last video a little bit about how um
these these POI hits can also be can be
thought of almost as like a musical
instrument in some respects
so there's a part of me that's hearing
like you know boom boom boom boom boom
doing like a little double time or life
God almost like a uh a drum fill or
something yeah let's even get one going
together here so boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom yeah so
boom boom oops
boom boom boom boom boom whoops so we
both start on the opposite too you start
down there I start
ah okay boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom I find I have more control on this
direction than I do this direction and
uh doing that set where you start
that way it forces the first beat to be
on the underside yeah it does so so is
that still a thing that's done or this
is literally just like playing around
with it getting some more I I know there
there are actually
parts of many dance like yeah or yeah
just dances or why to what have you they
have POI in it they do that motion but
it's typically paired with the second
POI and you're literally oh gotcha yeah
huh doing all sorts of stuff do not ask
me to do that I I cannot do that all
right one more time so uh we take that
off the top bottom top pump bottom top
bottom top bump bump bottom top bum
cool
that sounds like a dial up
[Music]
the bloopers from this are going to be
great thanks so much Tosh for once again
teaching me some awesome Maori style
short boy uh be on the lookout because
uh I'm also going to have a video where
I talk with Tosh some about what it was
like growing up with uh boy around her
keep your eyes peeled that we'll be
dropping real soon if you got anything
out of this video please make sure to
leave a like comment share and subscribe
in order to help other people find it to
help keep the conversation going and to
help my channel grow hey there friends
once again just wanted to give a quick
shout out to potiki POI who made the
short POI that I was using in this video
as I was learning from Tash just to
clarify because a couple people had this
question after the last video Tosh has
nothing to do with potiki POI she did
not make these POI potiki POI is based
in New Zealand Tosh is local uh she's
just my friend who is showing me the
ropes so appreciate you Tosh and
appreciate potiki POI I will go ahead
and leave a link floatiki POI dot Co dot
NZ if you want to pick up a sit for
yourself down in the description as
walls appear on screen thanks once again
to potiki POI for hooking me up here
this video would not be possible word
not for the awesome support of all of
these nice people right here these are
my flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently supporter and
you'd like to become one you can do that
by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and signing up there you
can get early access to all of my
content as well as a host of other
awesome rewards go check that out please
and thank you and hey if you'd like to
watch more videos where I am learning
Maori short POI style I'm going to leave
a link to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get outside and flow today and
I'll see with a new video real soon
peace